[Music]
ship continues to fly over Chicago as if
it's a tour or something couldn't it
have not flown over Chicago couldn't
have gone to
I don't know space why would
millennia-old robot aliens have a
similar visual aesthetic take on nights
and night them on a ship the size of
Texas an idiot from Texas will now
accidentally trigger an important thing
pirate lucky ass sword fires photon
torpedoes here and the next scene sword
will prepare them breakfast and figure
out how to get Tessa her scholarship
money now back to the tonguing the girls
leg see the arms of this nightshift
attached we can break free it's a
separate gem well of course it is
detaching from the main ship is what
good prisons do don't look down
impossible and impractical advice you
want not 18 years old yet you can do
what I say so good only a few families
will die from this but thank God Tess is
okay I'm not all that surprised ex
machina didn't no one during the
production step forward and say you know
real people would actually fall and die
here this is kind of impossible not even
one of the extras for a grip I'm gonna
pause the movie a moment put an arrow
here pointing at this building logo and
implore the film to read these letters
aloud to itself we interrupt this
Transformers film to bring you a little
spider-man I honestly did not expect
that but it still being simple we really
just destroying Chicago again and
another Transformers movie wow that's
great kid don't get cocky
[Music]
drivers honking or oblivious to alien
technology flying past them see I don't
think human beings could survive this
either and definitely not this but hey
BlueCross BlueShield on the scene so
maybe anything's possible
also Chicago went back to normal almost
immediately after the big huge alien
ship had everyone running and scared for
their lives a minute ago and the ship
never left the skyline did the CIA
somehow tell all of Chicago don't worry
about that alien ship I know you're
scared after aliens destroyed the city
nearly five years ago but go back to
what you were doing nothing to see here
this is an orgy of evidence that Michael
Bay is a whore who turns tricks for
money you better have insurance
wha-wha prepare for interstellar launch
shoot I have been preparing for the
launch of that movie since the fog cast
was announced I am pumped
oh we're not talking about the movie are
you lock down we'll be in deep space
before he realizes I'm God
but why lockdowns lack of curiosity
about all the that went down just a
minute ago is a curious plot oversight
even for this movie and seriously this
ship doesn't know when it's smaller
ships are detaching from it worst alien
ship ever how the fuck is Optimus
totally okay right now he couldn't even
move his arms after the lockdown attack
and then he was immediately hung upside
down in a prison you CIA guys really
subtle who he continually points out the
stupidity of its characters and plot as
if that makes it okay isn't this the
same Space Lab that Optimus and the
others destroyed 30 minutes ago they
clean that up in no time
within that man-made prototype I fought
I sense the presence of Megatron well
duh was it because he has Megatron's
face maybe hey hook me up to Megatron
and that man wasn't as dead as they
thought thanks for waiting a super long
time to share this crucial information
dickweed
that's just Megatron reincarnated you
knew this and you didn't warn them
little girl
you will go to a pretty dark place when
you are in death row just like the
screenwriter went into a dark place
where he couldn't see that he wrote this
illogical nonsense going after the seed
wait the seed my sentiments exactly why
not the matrix of leadership or the
Allspark or the pillars our creators
destroy your world to make us according
to dictionary.com destroy is a verb
meaning to reduce an object to useless
fragments a useless form or remains as
by rending burning or dissolving enter
beyond repair or renewal demolish ruin
annihilate
does that sound like what happened to
Earth he wants to detonate that seed in
the biggest city and kill millions let's
talk about Megatron's plan it's dumb and
requires way too many lucky things to
happen for it to work the end in case
you confused it with Beijing Sweden next
month we detonate safely in the
Mongolian desert but she not already
know this also he made a video or a
PowerPoint presentation for every single
step in his evil secret plan didn't eat
it's not a Transformers movie if we
don't bed down for the night somewhere
unconventional and have a heart-to-heart
relationship conversation no one cares
about enough to protect her
somebody better be Wow he turned around
on this issue in hurry when did he get
to cheese personal phone number and how
has this phone he's using not been lost
or destroyed 15 times of this movie
already hijacked possible my ship how
did you let this happen
honestly how did you let this happen
your ship has awful security and no
sensors or alarms those bastards could
have played laser tag on your ship and
you wouldn't have noticed together we're
gonna end human warfare we're about to
build a fully automated US Army Carol
tells Joshua a bunch of stuff that is
surely already understood between them
man was kept secret from the audience
for basically no reason find arcing to
bring your car around downstairs quietly
oh you fine I see phrasing why do they
even ever need to take a robot form or
any solid form at all
[Music]
and then the rest of the movie takes
place in Hong Kong which is not only not
the largest city in the world but not
even in the top five largest cities in
China when I fixed you was for a reward
the money knows me making a mistake
yeah but the alternative was either
turning him in for a reward a mistake or
turning him in out of the goodness of
your heart which one also been a mistake
let's not also forget all the mistakes
that these dumbass Autobots make -
especially that asshole bumblebee that
said I don't know why Optimus Prime
would be moved by this speech in every
movie the mistake is stupidity and there
ain't no cure for that unless you look
at all the junk see the treasure and
half a prime know he can be for
transformers movies this bloated and
stupid and they've made 3.7 billion
worldwide
that's seeing the treasure in the junk
that doesn't make me have faith in
humanity also puny human has to give the
seeing the potential Inhumans pep talk
to Optimus fucking Prime a guy that
invented the seeing the potential
Inhumans pep talk
also this is really all any transformers
or Superman movie has to offer in the
way of a moral the director said let's
have you eat a doughnut in every scene
it'll make you look like even more of a
theft now we're in a damn Bourne movie I
seriously think Bay just tries to one-up
other action films and he's just using
the transformer series as a vehicle to
that end
she'd be true if you know it's here then
why do you need help finding it you can
obviously sense its presence
who the hell's aboard that
and I said well nope not only possible
but about 95% probable how do you know
what's that this is a piece of lockdown
ship you've been a sleeping truck most
of this movie
why did Kade make this trip he's
actually and I can't believe I'm saying
this more useless than Sam Witwicky he
doesn't have any special artifacts or
knowledge or skill at killing
Decepticons he could have stayed in the
u.s. and kept his family safe but nope
he has to make the trip to China for
some reason oh yeah and that's another
thing even the transforming is lazy now
if I wanted to see the constant
recreations of that stupid scene from
the Covenant I'd go to YouTube find the
official trailer and skip to the 156
mark constantly how is he missing
why doesn't he still have his badass
alien gun and the humans in this movie
are harder to kill than the transformers
garage inventor holds his own versus a
highly trained CIA guy it's time for
reinforcements you had access to these
reinforcements this entire time and you
didn't use them already is it really
that hard to map out an action scene so
that I know where everyone is oh look
Optimus reached the level four boss I
hear he's tough to beat but if you have
enough mana you can usually get through
it it only took 10 hours of Transformers
movies for Grimlock to show up we're
giving you freedom one punch is all it
takes to break the will of this pussy
Dinobot you sure you want this thing in
battle with you being so easy to defeat
them all Roger for drugs okay that's
definitely racist reincarnation of
Megatron somehow forgot the last three
movies when his plans were foiled
usually due to horrible planning
fire-breathing technique could also have
roasted bumblebee but get that seed
safely to the hills
why don't you can take it wouldn't it be
safer faster smarter a better idea in
almost every way we got a call to
central government for help
we also have to speak English for one of
the four sentences in this scene for
some reason wait this ship had this
magnet thing and lockdown didn't want to
use it to vacuum Optimus Prime up the
million or so times he had the chance to
capture the guy just in case you
confused it with Beijing Alberta Canada
pterodactyl bond somehow misses the
amazing pull of the magnet even as it
flies directly into its path entire
boats are flying up but the small
vehicle somehow finds a way to avoid
getting sucked into the air and sucking
up now I'm dropping it is lockdown
sitting near the magnet and surveying
all the junk that comes into the ship
and saying nope not Optimus Prime that's
not Optimus Prime
that's definitely not Optimus Prime send
it all back down we'll do this as
inefficiently as possible until the
movie calls for me to do something else
that's stupid
oh now the magnet works on the car
kelsey grammer shows up to a random spot
in Hong Kong where he could make his
presence felt in the plot again or does
he optimist up to his eyeballs in
fighting lockdown manages to sneak a
shot to kill Harrell before he blows
away Kade Kade runs up to this wall to
shoot lockdown and it turns into a
completely different wall in the next
shot but that's not so disturbing who
the fuck is this dude where did he come
from you see the ghost from three men
and a baby
handy truck with tow cable is available
at the site and Shane and Tessa figure
out a convoluted plan to use it in like
five seconds after seeing it you haven't
done anything yet lockdown as missiles
and right I was he trying to do anything
else to Kade right now in fact he could
probably blow up the truck while he's at
it
there's really no reason he has to lose
this fight you see my facial I see stuff
then do it already can't wait to hear
what both artifact exists in the next
movie that will bring these crazy kids
back together for movies main villain
turns out to not actually be important
to the story in any real way they don't
have a home dad I might be able to help
you with that
aren't you going to jail for like
forever I shall take it where it can
never be found
that parallax planet we ever see you
again only if they greenlight a fifth
movie before this one hits theaters oh
wait this motherfucker can fly just like
the original cartoons but not the first
three movies of this franchise leave
planet earth the lawn because I'm coming
for you do you mean that transformers 5
might actually have the chance to be
about robots fighting this time instead
of some stupid human drama that gets in
the way because I'll sign up for that as
long as it's not 15 hours long like this
one
[Music]
to kill you
three-two-one
[Music]
[Applause]
you think maybe something should never
be invented
[Music]
truck guys as dependable as the trucks
they drive it's been sucky around here
lately but we're gonna be fine sweetie
you just gotta keep believing okay
until you go ahead Brian I am listening
[Music]
I'm an inventor this could be a
game-changer for me say how do your
mother for me okay listen people you
have any idea who you're dealing with
this is Jason Bourne
[Music]
[Applause]
how did they find the island they'll
have to ask when we get here I don't
have to ask
you brought them here well to mind
welcome to mind and look I want a lawyer
I want a lawyer man can't scare me with
this Gestapo crap I know my rights
but tricking the probe by hiding under
the boats of another super oh man I'm
still kicking about
you've got the touch you got the back
[Music]
my daddy taught me good a are no good
aliens or bad aliens Yeager guys did you
let's time gadget but whenever you look
to the Stars think of one of them as my
soul
[Music]
by the way I'm totally legit I just got
picked up by Red Bull Red Bull gives you
wings